>>> WELCOME BACK TO "CBS THIS
MORNING."
TWO FORMER POLICE OFFICERS IN
LOVELAND, COLORADO, WERE CHARGED
WITH CRIMES YESTERDAY FOR THE
VIOLENT ARREST OF A 73-YEAR-OLD
WOMAN WITH DEMENTIA.
THIS IS A CASE WE'VE REPORTED ON
FOR WEEKS.
BODY CAMERA VIDEO SHOWS OFFICER
AUSTIN HOPP TACKLING KAREN
GARNER LAST JUNE.
HE'S ACCUSED OF FELONY ASSAULT
AND OTHER CHARGES.
HIS FORMER PARTNER IS CHARGED
WITH FAILURE TO REPORT USE OF
FORCE.
GARNER WAS LEFT WITH A BROKEN
ARM AND DISLOCATED SHOULDER.
IN AN EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEW, HER
DAUGHTER TOLD OUR LEAD NATIONAL
CORRESPONDENT DAVID BEGNAUD THE
CHARGES ARE NOT ENOUGH.
DAVID, GOOD MORNING.
>> Reporter: GOOD MORNING.
KAREN GARNER'S FAMILY IS
THRILLED THAT THE OFFICERS
INVOLVED WILL BE PROSECUTED.
BUT THIS DECISION TOOK NEARLY A
YEAR TO COME DOWN.
THE FAMILY BELIEVES THAT THE
GARNER CASE WAS REALLY SWEPT
UNDER THE RUG BY THE ENTIRE
POLICE DEPARTMENT, AND THEY
BELIEVE THAT MORE PEOPLE NEED TO
BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR WHAT
HAPPENED TO KAREN.
>> I MEAN, THEY'RE BEING CHARGED
FOR SOMETHING.
IT'S JUST NOT -- IT'S NOT
ENOUGH.
>> Reporter: ALLISA SWARTZ SAYS
HER MOTHER, KAREN GARNER, WILL
NEVER BE THE SAME AFTER HER
ENCOUNTER WITH LOVELAND POLICE
OFFICERS LAST SUMMER.
>> DO YOU NEED TO BE ARRESTED
RIGHT NOW?
NO, NO, NO.
OKAY.
LET'S STOP.
COME ON.
>> I'M GOING HOME -- I'M GOING
HOME.
>> Reporter: THIS WAS JUNE 26th,
2020.
THEN-OFFICER AUSTIN HOPP TACKLED
KAREN GARNER, A 73-YEAR-OLD,
80-POUND WOMAN WITH DEMENTIA TO
THE GROUND, CUFFING HER AND
REFUSING TO LET HER GO HOME.
SHE HAD BEEN ACCUSED OF STEALING
$13.88 WORTH OF ITEMS FROM THE
NEARBY WALMART.
STORE SECURITY CAUGHT HER, AND
SHE RETURNED THE ITEMS.
WALMART CALLED THE POLICE, AND
OFFICERS PURSUED HER.
>> WE DON'T PLAY THIS GAME.
IF YOU TRY TO KICK ME, THIS IS
GOING TO BE BAD.
>> Reporter: OFFICER DARIA
JALALI WAS ON THE SCENE AND CAME
AROUND TO ASSIST OFFICER HOPP
WHILE THEY RESTRAINED GARNER.
>> OW!
>> Reporter: GARNER'S SHOULDER
WAS DISLOCATED, AND HER ARM
BROKEN.
>> AUSTIN HOPP USED EXCESSIVE
FORCE IN THE ARREST OF MISS
GARNER, AND THAT RESULTED IN
SERIOUS
DARIA JALALI FAILED TO LIVE UP
TO HER DUTIES UNDER THE LAW AND
AS A SWORN PEACE OFFICER.
>> Reporter: THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY ANNOUNCED YESTERDAY
THAT HE WAS CHARGING BOTH
OFFICERS.
>> I UNDERSTAND THAT --
>> Reporter: THERE IS VIDEO FROM
THE JAIL SHOWING GARNER TELLING
THE OFFICERS SHE'S IN PAIN.
SHE SAYS IT MORE THAN 30 TIMES.
SHE WAS DENIED MEDICAL CARE FOR
MORE THAN SIX HOURS.
>> TORTURE HAS BEEN EXPOSED HERE
--
>> Reporter: FAMILY ATTORNEY
SARAH SCHIELKE SAYS THAT THREE
MORE OFFICERS SHOULD ALSO BE
CHARGED INCLUDING AT LEAST ONE
WHO WAS CAPTURED WATCHING
FOOTAGE OF GARNER'S ARREST WITH
OFFICERS HOPP AND JALALI.
>> I LOVE IT --
>> I HATE IT.
>> IT WENT UP THE CHAIN OF
COMMAND WITH -- ALONG WITH THE
VIDEOS THAT VARIOUS LEVELS OF
CHAIN OF COMMAND WATCHED, AND
NOBODY DID ANYTHING.
>> Reporter: THERE WILL BE
PEOPLE WHO ARE LIKE, AREN'T YOU
BEING A LITTLE PICKY AND ASKING
FOR A LITTLE TOO MUCH.
>> MY RESPONSE IS SIMPLE -- THIS
ALL HAPPENED NEARLY A YEAR AGO,
AND ALL OF THIS IS ONLY HEARD
BECAUSE WE FILED A LAWSUIT AND
WE RELEASED THE VIDEOS.
ALL OF THIS SPEAKS TO A CULTURE
AND AN ENVIRONMENT THAT MADE IT
POSSIBLE FOR THAT TO HAPPEN.
>> I FULLY SUPPORT THESE
CHARGES.
>> Reporter: THE POLICE CHIEF AT
LOVELAND, COLORADO, ROBERT
TICER, SAID HE DIDN'T SEE THE
VIDEOS UNTIL THIS APRIL -- TEN
MONTHS AFTER KAREN WAS ARRESTED.
>> QUESTIONS RELATED TO WHY AND
HOW LONG IT TOOK FOR THAT
NOTIFICATION TO OCCUR WILL NO
DOUBT OCCUR THROUGH THE CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION.
>> I FEEL LIKE THEY'RE STILL
LETTING EVERYBODY DOWN.
>> Reporter: KAREN'S DAUGHTER
BELIEVES BOTH TICER AND OTHER
SUPERVISORS NEED TO BE FIRED,
TOO.
>> MY MOM WOULD BE ASHAMED
BECAUSE SHE LOOKS UP TO THE
POLICEMEN IN UNIFORM.
THEY'RE THERE TO PROTECT YOU,
NOT TO HARM YOU.
>> YOU HAVE TO WONDER HOW DID
THE POLICE CHIEF NOT KNOW ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENED.
HE CLAIMS HE DIDN'T KNOW UNTIL A
YEAR AFTER THE INCIDENT.
BY THE WAY, THE DEPARTMENT HAS
UNDERGONE ALZHEIMER'S AWARENESS
TRAINING, THEY UNDERWENT THAT
IMMEDIATELY AFTER THE VIDEO CAME
TO LIGHT AFTER IT WAS RELEASED
BY THE FAMILY ATTORNEY.
AND THE DEPARTMENT ALSO PLANS TO
ENHANCE ITS DEESCALATION
TRAINING TECHNIQUES IN THE
COMING WEEKS AND MONTHS.
GUYS, BACK TO YOU.
>> IT DIDN'T HELP THAT LADY.
BUT HOPEFULLY IT WILL HELP
SOMEBODY ELSE.
THANK YOU.
WE WERE ASKING THE SAME QUESTION
AT THE TABLE, HOW COULD THE
POLICE CHIEF NOT KNOW?
>> NOT HAVE SEEN THE VIDEO FOR
SO LONG.
>> EXACTLY.
>> WHY WOULD YOU WATCH A WOMAN
IN PAIN AND SAY "I LOVE IT"?
>> I DON'TAND A A AND UNDERSTAN-
DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT.
YOU COULD TELL SOMETHING WAS
OFF.
THE NEED TO ARREST HER MYSTIFIES
ME.
>> SHE'S 73 YEARS OLD A